look at what the top guy does and do
twice as much as that guy does be Kobe
for whatever the job is he did three
practices a day while everyone else did
one or two because he wanted to get
ahead and in the beginning he was worse
than them and then he got as good as
them and then he became better than them
and he kept doing three practices a day
until eventually no one could catch up
the guy who's number one at whatever
that business is probably works better
than you and he works longer than you
and so you can't just match him to get
ahead because he'll always be happy you
gotta match his current effort and then
do your I'm gonna get ahead of you
effort when he clocks out is when your
work clocks in if you can really
internalize this you're gonna Crush
you're gonna win